hey babes
impracticaljokerslive.com 40 cities are
up we're adding more cities right now we
just added second shows in Portland
Boston the third show St Louis the
second show and we added one in Bangor
Maine and this week coming up Niagara
Falls on March 9th Newark New Jersey a
Prudential Center on 10th Wallingford on
the 11th Long Island at the UBS Arena on
the 12th this is next week and then
we're doing Green Bay Milwaukee and
Rosemont at the end of March there's way
more stuff online and
practicaljokerslive.com every single
Thursday night all new episodes right
now on True TV and we're also airing on
TBS watch the show uh TiVo the show it's
a TiVo watch it within three days thank
you for your support I'll see you on the
road the show has been insane by the way
and it's interactive and we're giving
away meet and greets check my socials on
IG I'm watching Impractical Jokers every
Thursday with post Malone having a Bud
Light and I'm telling you right now if
you go to
chrisdcomedy.com I'm doing all of
Florida in March so just go find a city
in Florida I'm doing it all the shows
almost sold out September 22nd Radio
City Music Hall New York City almost
sold out we might be adding a show
September 23rd in a New York venue so
just go get the tickets for Radio City
now and then I have all other shows I
have Boston I've Austin Texas go see all
the dates Vice Land TV network
Thursday uh Tuesday March 7th 10 p.m
imagine you're going up against me oh my
God
so he got your wings
Vice TV my new show
s from retro show we talk everything 70s
80s 90s it's an amazing show it's fun
and then you're watching practical
jokers Thursday
christiecomedy.com
salvocanocomedy.com TIG on only fans
that's where you'll find us
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away from your feelings babe don't
be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate to say hey babe hey babe hey
babe
[Music]
that was my idea for the opening song
and what I think about that idea and I
want you guys to go comment at hey babe
and I want you to go go on the patreon
and and I want you to know I want is
that was that intro so amazing and so
good that that is the intro of the show
from now on do we redo the intro and
it's just recording himself
and by the way I want to say cut this is
the first time we're doing hey babe live
from the new painted studio if you know
one thing about us you know we support
Ukraine and we prove that in the in the
paint design that's exactly right that's
exactly right we are anti-russia here
because we painted a we made a
commitment to pimp took it upon himself
until I painted the studio and I said
well I know who you like in the war
for a year in and we just want to show a
little support
do I have to bring the remote still to
get a nice little glow on this is that
my is that at my house did you find the
remote
oh you the remote oh okay so the plug in
the remote so so I don't know the way
speaking of glow whatever hair product
you're using today I'm into it I told
you that when I saw you immediately
because what I like about it is it's
falling in place it's one of you you got
the hair like it's I clearly put too
much product in my hair today I feels
like I'm wearing a helmet but you have
done your hair okay but it I could also
be convinced that you didn't do your
hair but I know you did your hair
because I smelled your hair product when
you got in so it smells good it's laying
softly it's styled but also messy it's
natch
yeah it was uh I love natties we love
gnats yeah it was like a like a matte
like light sculpting right material it's
it's one of those things where I didn't
here's the thing you wanna know the
secret I do
my lady styled my hair today because
here's the thing wait a second yeah yeah
no no because you're not gay no why no
no what no I don't know I am I am but I
told my guy my lady oh okay that's what
it said because I was like we're two gay
guys we're two gay men yes okay just
blow your mind no no because in order in
order to get this you need to blow dry
it and I'm not a good blow dryer I'm not
a good boy so my guy my guy Max yeah I
never could recreate what he does when I
leave right I try I fail so sometimes
when I really and I don't want to wear
like you know the hat or the [__]
slickback the only thing I do slick back
for is because if I don't do I would
never do slickback you'd think that's
slick back that's pushback that's push I
think you should leave greatest sketch
overall yes can't wait for season three
uh well and and our boy who by the way
how's her the actor Paul Walter Hauser
Paul Walter Hauser let me first of all
the ultimate Paul Walter Hauser I am on
a Paul Walter Hauser press run Paul
Walter house we spoke about him two
weeks ago on hey
no that well yes that Paul Walter house
I did Joe Rogan a couple of days ago I
talked about Paul Walter Hauser and
Blackbird for maybe 20 minutes of the
show had Rogan not seen it he had not
seen it he didn't know who Hauser was
and I almost said I almost said Joe get
the [__] off my show yeah you know Paul
Walters you should have said that and
and now again
Paul Walter Hauser who was who was I I
think had the funniest sketch and I
think you should leave yeah
um uh which um Tim uh Robinson isn't
even in it's just he I'm sure he wrote
something I love about that show yeah
which is he he doesn't have to take all
the credit because that shows he's such
a brilliant mind you can see when he's
not in him where he would be yeah but I
love that they put like and a lot of the
people they put in there I think are
just like well they are they're like
regular like they're not comedic actors
like a lot of the like the extra like
you know the one line is the day guys
which and that plays really well too
because it it comes across like an
authentic well you mentioned too before
that you blow dry your hair and there's
three things that I think the everyday
human does that I don't do or that I've
done so sparing in my life that it would
count as less than less than 0.000 one
percent of my life I've done these I've
not done one of these three things that
humans do all the time did you just have
a stroke yes okay
but I'm back now okay
um because of intermittent fasting my
Strokes have gotten less and less
understood
I don't blow dry my hair which just
things people do all the time I yeah I
go through phases but yeah I don't blow
dry my hair I don't use Q-tips in my
ears after the shower and wash out the
earwax
I don't even know you
third thing I don't brush my tongue when
I'm brushing my teeth wow those are
three things I don't do but yet I'm
still clean I'm still hygienic I still
can hear my breath smells decent yeah I
can't live without putting a Q-tip in my
ear you put it in every day if I don't
have a Q-tip to put my ear I can't live
but how much wax are you building up
each day that you have to cut it's not
about the wax because I was like I'm
doing it every day so there kind of is
no wax buildup it's like a mental first
of all I love the feeling my ear is
itchy sometimes so I love the feeling
and second of all I get the water out of
my ears by doing it as well but you know
what it's nice because we're as men we
always penetrate today it's nice to be
penetrated once in a while yeah you're
not you don't have to do a full gay sex
it always depends on it depends on the
whole but penetration in some holes that
are not sexually in nature can be nice a
penetration in a non-sexual hole all day
people ask me all the time Chris why do
you pick your nose every day I said
because I want to be penetrated but I'm
not gay but I still do want to feel what
it's like to be inside my hall and
that's what I do that and that's how you
deal with the Q10 that's great and I'm
you don't have to go you can feel that
as a man and not have to have full set
you don't have to have sex with the man
to feel penetrated yeah pimp has
something to say yes uh Harvard Health
says do not clean your ears they're
self-cleaning I know I know what
Harvard's Health says but well listen I
I can't Harvard Health that I didn't
know my ears were a [__] Roomba yeah
that's oh [__]
when you were done talking I was gonna
say
oh we should have heard that and they
even say it's bad for you and I don't
know what to do about that man because
what I do is I got a Q-tip the second I
wake up I have a routine I wake up are
you honest I get out of bed I go into
the bathroom I put water on my face so
wash up a little wash my hands I pee and
I put a Q-tip and I do a Q-tip because
my ears are like itchy a little bit and
then after the shower I do another Q-tip
to get the water out twice doubling up
on the Queue and honestly I failed a
hearing test when I was a young boy and
I never went back you know why I was
nervous and I think that I I probably am
doing damage to my long-term hearing I
would say almost 100 with 100 certainty
even though I'm not a Harvard Health uh
Advocate or I don't work for the
hartfordhealth.com yeah but you're a
cool guy from Brooklyn I am a cool guy
from Brooklyn that you know uh that has
too much hair product in I will say that
I do think for almost for sure you've
damaged your hearing I know doing you've
overdone it with the Q-tips I know and I
still do it every day it's once in a
blue I go in too far and I hit something
and I sh I literally Shiver I go oh does
that pain subside it takes like
30 SEC 20 seconds have you gotten
anything and I was like that's bad I did
whatever I just did there is bad when's
the last chocolate protein chick when's
the last time you don't have to get your
protein in uh an hour after the gym
that's a myth by the way is that right
that's a myth that we can talk about it
I thought you needed to do it right then
tank Sinatra told me tank Sinatra told
me when tank Sinatra talks people listen
people listen tank told me I thought
that you had to get because I had a
question for tanked I said you know I'm
doing this intermittent fasting but I'm
working out in the morning I said but
how am I supposed to work out at 7 A.M
and not have my protein shake till 11AM
I'm not in the hour window that I need
to take my protein shake in or else it
doesn't work on your muscles and he
called me up and he said first things he
said let me ask you a question are you a
stupid [__] and I said yes yeah and
why and he said yours I knew that he
said because how do you still think that
you have to take a protein shake within
an hour of working out I said because
that's what every health and fitness
magazine every or every coach every
nutrition expert I've ever talked to I
said if you don't if you don't take that
protein shake within an hour of working
out don't even take the protein you
might as well be emaciated yeah you
literally you're it will not get into
your muscles he was like do you think
your body
over the billions of years of
engineering I said well somebody's
listened to a little much too much
Graham Hancock I don't know that we're
that old I subscribe to that you know we
are human DC yeah we're we're not as old
as we've been here 2023 years that's it
that's the only time Jesus made us all
right and I I said to him but there was
people before Christ some people say
that the first group of people was 5000
BC the Sumerians but then according to
Graham Hancock and ancient apocalypse on
Netflix I'm not talking about him
because I just did Joe Rogan I because
uh according to Graham Hancock uh that
we're much much older than 5000 BC like
you know 7 000 years old much much older
there was a thing called the younger
driest impact Theory which wiped out
civilization he believed civilization
could have been as advanced as it is
today and then was wiped off to the face
of the Earth by a comet meteor that
caused a huge Title Wave and an ice age
and wiped all any evidence of Life off
the planet as as advanced as we are
today it's a mind-blowing thing to think
about he said I read it I'm telling you
right now I'm getting uh daily my
anxiety is shooting through the roof
about AI daily I'm getting articles from
Friends left and right I read something
in the journal Wall Street uh last night
that basically says and I didn't know
this already but it's in more straight
terms that like it has been kicked off
and we cannot reverse it already already
and it's compounding at a rate that
we're not understanding and you thought
it wasn't to be able to touch comedy
well it is because pimp has got this
chat GPT thing it's gonna and then what
I think we should do in a little bit
when Once pimp gets it fired up let's
put some prompts into it and see if this
thing can do the podcast for us or I've
already had friends sent me this and
they said do a joke in the style of Sal
vulcano and it and it does dude it's
it's not a joke or anything but so I
guess it is me but uh no but but no but
it it is it's wild I don't know where it
Garners or gathers the information of
the sensibility the sensibility is off
but it makes a joke you know and we did
it for everybody we started we did one
for DeRosa and the Roses was a little
bit curmudgeonly so it was kind of fun
it was kind of fun so but I'm getting
I'm really scared about that so he told
me so going back tank Sinatra the
younger driest you know all that um he's
like when his lady when they have sex or
whatever do you think that he's referred
to as tank at any point I think that she
does I think that I think I think I
think I've been missing out if they
don't but here's the thing I've known
tank Sinatra for I want to say upwards
of four years I just recently I'm
talking about two weeks ago found out
his real name is George I didn't know
that I thought his name was tank well
George Sinatra doesn't have the same
ring to it yeah it's not as good
um but he said you don't have to drink
protein you can go up to like eight plus
hours your body is this is this machine
that if you don't get he said the
protein industry the protein shake
industry made it one hour so you have to
get it in right away but it's all cut
it's all [__] cash all yeah so so
smart so say people I hate people so he
said you don't you should have it if
you're gonna go on 72-hour fast and work
out that's not recommended but if you
work out at 8am and you don't have to
eat till and you can't eat and you're
fasting till noon then wait till noon
it's not your body it will do literally
nothing
the body is Wonderland
what song was that John Mayer you took
out the a he said your body is
Wonderland and then you went up to a
pitch I haven't heard thank you I love
you singing Love It I think you should
put out a serious album I really do I
think it would sell as a comedy album
but do it serious like dead serious dead
serious like like uh now that's what I
call Krista Stefano it just the covers
you know do you guys want to try the the
robot hell yeah but no prompt it yeah
pimp Pimp's growing his beard an extra
inch and I like it oh in time for spring
yeah you're doing the reverse here we go
so is this is chat GPT just a website
I just was wondering because you saw
that guy that spoke to you saw the big
article the guy that spoke to it and
they went South and the guy was like
you're in a bad you're in a bedroom
marriage I love you I'm gonna take you
know and then he also said that like if
I had to say what I would feel like if I
was gonna be sentient or whatever he was
like I'm tired of being trapped here I
want to overcome you and then they just
were like oh yeah that's cool don't
worry about it but like I wonder now if
people are like even just like Wayward
teens aren't going on to this thing and
being like I'm gonna kill you like and
seeing what it says back like are people
pushing the limits with this thing like
would you find it would you be
intimidated right now probably not but
to go on there and because he might
remember because like it whatever this
thing is if it if it remembers it might
come after you later I don't know I
don't want to score in the chat it's
like Terminator you don't know right so
if you got on there right now and
started running your mouth to this thing
and challenging it is do you think that
that might be something that is risky
and neutral could be like you know like
Justin Trudeau it could be blackface in
the future you know you really don't
know you have to be careful here we go
that was a
that was a unique comparison why don't
we and by the way the name of this
episode is blackface of the future yes
um here we go pimp prompted it do us
joke in the style of Sal vulcano
I went to the doctor the other day and
he told me to stop Matt
good boy on my own
he goes it's like a cat skill I went to
the doctor because I went to the I went
to the doctor the other day and he told
me to stop masturbating I asked him why
and he said because I'm trying to
examine you
um so he so they took a joke that's
already been done a million times then I
put do a joke in style of Christmas
Stefano I hate doing laundry every time
I'm folding clothes I feel like I'm
playing a game of Tetris with my
underwear and let me tell you trying to
fit a thong in my boxers is like trying
to fit a square peg into a round hole it
just doesn't work folks who I have an
idea yeah I have an idea we have to
commit to it
we we have to keep asking and get a
whole set and go on stage I could comedy
stuff to a stand or whatever and do that
do that Crush do that no we don't tell
them yeah yeah we don't want it to do
that oh really pitch this yeah yeah oh
that is down where we're trying that is
crazy I would do that I would do that
come do it then I just have to remember
these [__] jokes well no we could
bring this thing up there shut up you
should print it up and then I wrote but
you're gonna see just tell them you're
gonna say this is the chat gbd joke yeah
no I think you reveal halfway
you don't do it you don't reveal oh okay
yeah it's all I'll tell I put tell and
then I wrote tell me about homeless
pimps beard said I'm sorry I cannot
provide any information about his beard
as it is inappropriate and offensive
as a as an AI language model I am
programmed to provide respectful and
helpful responses oh he thinks you're an
actual homeless yeah
it's a shame she whatever so I wonder
now if you put if you put another
another joke to you again will it shoot
back the same joke I wonder now like if
I could say Sal like like have this
thing write a sitcom pitch for us and
then go to the networks and Pitch the
sitcom you can because my My Writers
like last year will like check this out
and they were like write an Impractical
Jokers bit oh this has been around for a
long time well this season like whatever
I remember a month a couple months back
they were like check this out like write
a write a packet for impractical right
my sweater too short do you think I'm
wearing too short of sweaters now
because I'm getting excited about being
a 36 waist should I go back to a longer
sweater no it looks fine you just step
back so I can understand the ratio what
do you think but I don't know if you got
nothing in the front here like if you're
flat in the front you wear that because
I feel I'm dressing up a little bit like
a like a woman now just Style
you're dressing more adult adult-like
and you're dressing you like for me I'm
like I'm relegated probably because I
don't feel as confident as you do in
what I have exactly but I I I shoot for
Comfort up top a lot like yeah you know
I I have so many sweaters and
sweatshirts and I even boots but I'm
like why am I gonna wear
boots and a sweater if I could be
comfortable right but I think that
you're just more comfortable overall and
I appreciate that and I because you're
you know you're a friend first you're a
man we kind of don't see these things
but when I ask the question is my
sweater too short I shot a look at
vanity and her face said yes her face
said your sweater is too short and I
don't like this new you so the females
don't necessarily like what I'm doing
because her face said absolutely [__]
not Chris you need to get a longer
sweater the next time you come in here I
want you to be wearing a maxi pad dress
first off I'm obsessed with the color
story today love the green it just looks
like
we've been playing off each other it's
shrunk but is it too short no no I I
yeah because it's true oh has that
shrunk it must have shrunk no it's
shrunk I've seen you wear this before I
love it
showing me saying I'm not I'm repeating
outfits
some styles are like I would say I would
say it's not offensive I would say it's
a borderline okay well here I am I'm
wearing a scissor me Daddy ass no
T-shirt and you know that's my way of
dressing these days it's what now what
is that I do realize it is that TT Jerry
merch I do realize that if people don't
get the reference they're just gonna
think it's my own merch it's wrestling
it's wrestling yeah shout out to the
acclaimed everybody loves the acclaimed
I would like to point out chriscaster my
boy Bowens sleeves of your suit on Jimmy
Kimmel looked uncomfortable so what
happened was is shout out sorry so what
happened is I did the Jimmy Kimmel show
shout out shout out JK
um had a great time I gotta get you guys
up I gotta get us a monitor in here yeah
I gotta get it my uh my new show on Vice
starts uh next week
um uh March uh 7th uh 10 p.m right
that's right Venetia right March 7 10
p.m on Vice it's called the super
maximum retro show
um it's all about 70s 80s 90s so I was
on there to promote it because Jimmy uh
Kim was the executive producer all so I
went in the show and I got a beautiful I
got a beautiful suit beautiful suit uh
from my boy Giovanni brushiani who makes
great shoots yeah I went to high school
with him an Italian with red hair
Giovanni russiani Giovanni [__]
brushiani wow so so like he was destined
to make suits yes and and great great
beautiful suit that I wore what I I got
so hooked in the moment that when I
walked out and sat on the couch I had I
went like this when I came out like put
two fists up like as if like yeah we did
it didn't and then the sleeves never
came never came down and then I sat in
the chair and I knew the first thing I
thought of when I sat in the chair you
were doing the turtleneck look right the
turtleneck look yeah this right here
yeah the first thing I did is I knew I
felt the back of my suit up like this
and I said I'm just gonna deal with that
whatever I didn't even think that my
like the sleeves like and the whole the
whole segment the the turtleneck is here
like the white tournament here I swear
to Chrysler my sleeve was up here oh my
gold bracelet was around the sleeve and
my watch I looked like an absolute idiot
it was almost but you might be confident
to pull it off and you look amazing in
it but then unfortunate change of events
yeah you got brushing
it was so bad because the suit is
beautiful bresciani texted me he goes
great I swear to Christ he goes great
job on Kimmel I should have made you
longer sleeves he knew at least he knows
he knows and he was like that and I was
like no gee that's not your fault you
make unbelievable I mean the suit is
amazing and he gave me two other suits
if you're looking for a suit Giovanni
brushian is your guy and and um but
you're gonna like the way you look
you're gonna like the way you've I
guarantee Giovanni bresciani guarantees
it so so the sleeves were so high but
it's one of those things got caught
caught up in the moment Colin Quinn by
the way shout out Colin Quinn my first
time ever on the couch so I was very
nervous because when you're doing stand
up you're in control when you're on the
couch yes you're in control they ask you
leading questions but it's a little bit
like you're improving i i people either
do the couch good or they don't right
because they they pre-asked the
questions right but you know Jimmy and
you probably could you and you know I
physically met him
him and I went to dinner but you but
you're in business with him
and call him yeah because honestly like
I I hate that thing where you're like
you're you're telling I don't like doing
material on the couch I hate it it never
plays right well I'll tell a story so
that's what Colin Quinn's advice was he
was like you know he's on the couch a
million times he said you gotta go in
there with at least two things that you
know you're gonna get to and he said
they should be older bits that are very
very well established because he said
the amount of people who who don't know
you in that studio is going to be higher
because you're podcasting and stand up
and they're older and they're TV
audience whatever going with two bits
that you know will do well even at that
are story oriented but they're old bits
so I did like a bit from my first
special like just let into it and then a
bit from my second special and I was
just and I'm so happy I did that because
then it made me make a conversational
right no it was all conversation and
then because it it got big laughs and
then it just kind of you know my anxiety
went here and then I started popping in
the moment yeah yeah but my sleeves were
so high I I gotta I'm so excited to
watch it I need to watch it now nine
minutes it was a nine minutes that's a
lot after Anthony Mackey Captain America
wow when I walked back into the green
room after I was finished my second
Captain America Anthony Mackey he was
walking out and he said yo man where'd
you get those glasses he did that's
exactly what he said I was like I was
like um I got him from the Anthony Ayden
on the Lower East Side he's gonna have
to check them out
I was like have a great day Captain
America and he went like this
I was like that was Black Panther but
you didn't call him no no wrong no when
he I said have a good day I know he's
Captain America but when he went like
this I said that he's Captain America
Captain America
okay here's what I would have done right
he's great Anthony ready you be Anthony
Mackey I'll be you okay I'm Anthony
ready word in the back go ahead yo
where'd you get those glasses
take him that's what I would have did to
him man white people are good people
yeah you would you wouldn't establish
you guys would that would have been a
daughter maybe a possible friendship
right there I I give you the glasses off
my face Anthony I'm giving to you right
now because I know I got to connect to
my boy Anthony Ayden down in St Marks
and Second Avenue also and though you
look his glasses go great with the
Giovanni bresciani suit I Anthony Aiden
would have gotten me a second pair of
glasses he would do that for me yeah
yeah uh so like how great is Jimmy
Kimmel's like green room area it's a bar
right the bar now after covet they don't
do the bar anymore oh dude it was a
party in there yeah it was a party it
was a band that was there I forgot what
band was the only one everyone's in
there just drinking and playing music
all I heard about in The Green Room of
after I did the Jimmy Kimmel show from
his staff uh Rory Albanese is there a
great you know is that where Rory is
Rory works there now but he was great
Comics he's over there but all I heard
not from him because I think he just
started working there but from the older
guy of the from the staff who's been
there for 20 years all I heard was so
happy to have a great time wish we were
here or three years ago was a party wish
you were here yeah because they every
time and then and then even when I was
getting you know you got to go through
hair and makeup or whatever and even
they were like man this used to be a
party but they but they did say now that
the covet is like kind of really like
relaxing now they they're gonna bring it
back to do it now yeah yeah yeah but
shout out Jimmy Kimmel uh really great
guy love Sal shout out Jimmy Kimmel's
son fan of hey babe we if you're
listening which we actually know that
you are we know that you are yeah so so
uh thank you and uh yeah oh very nice I
do want to know what you were sniffing
on Joe Rogan what the hell was that
about those are smelling salts so you
ever do it I did The Joe Rogan first
time doing first time ever how'd that
come about he has smelling salts he
likes to give them to the guests
just have a little fun oh just the
experience of it yeah just have a look
and I was very scared for the first time
just a just a couple years ago on camera
uh I was doing doing a bit and I I was
surprised at the I was like oh [__] yeah
like if you're if you're out if you're
unconscious and you smell it I could see
how it works he said Theo Von does it
religiously interesting what is it
supposed to do it when you get knocked
out it's there to you know it wakes
people up because it's so profound when
you're not kind of uh you know knocked
out it gave me because I had said before
because I had landed in Austin at 5am I
had done I did you know I was I had done
a theater I had so the night before so
here was my week please here's my week
last you know Tuesday this is on Tuesday
I go to Vancouver do a show in Vancouver
Shadow Vancouver where'd you do the show
Vogue theater you did Queen Elizabeth I
think only the book oh maybe I'm wrong
was it very old yes either was very old
yes Green Room was downstairs yes stage
was hot yep yes I think I did the vote
yeah they had a microphone lights no I'm
wondering if it was in a very old
theater yes downstairs was like a couch
a fridge yeah stickers on it yes yes
okay I did that yeah how was the crowd
the crowd actually was good okay did you
not like that my Vogue crowd uh which
was my last stop on the tour okay on my
whole tour my old crowd was
ossified drunk and every like there was
like I mean you know a small group
wounded for everybody but there was like
10 drunk people
that not only didn't stop talking they
were just getting up walking to the
stage and nobody did I I there's only so
much you could I could [__] Canadians
and I was so excited because Vancouver
is one of my favorite places on Earth
but I had it was that thing the next day
where like everybody that was in that
theater that wasn't that was like typing
be like we're so sorry that's not
Vancouver right so sorry like those
people were terrible you know but it was
like it was a it was like a not a not
not a good show
I was there on a Tuesday night I'm sorry
my show was on a Wednesday night Tuesday
yeah that's a song right with Drake
Drake's artist yeah and then you know
that's the song right yeah
I did mushrooms uh because mush I did
just for laughs
the Just for Laughs they had mushrooms
for the comics I need you to stop
I need you to stop it's legal so you
went to Vancouver JFL Vancouver and you
had your own show at the Vogue yep the
crowd was good who was there with you I
got a bone to pick with you Jared freed
fun uh Tommy Tommy tour manager Tommy
the tour Tommy Taurus we call them
good kid God bless him um he's got hair
like TT Jerry
um Tommy Taurus
um who else was there with me
um um um
who else was there that's that's it
yeah okay yeah yeah yeah you and John
fried yeah yeah yeah yeah so so oh my
friend Pat Finnegan was there with us oh
all right yeah of course uh so wait so
where was you were at the hotel with all
the comics and that's where the
mushrooms were they had JFL have you
ever done mushrooms yeah I did a little
stinker oh no I took a bite of it with a
little stinker on Chrissy chaos okay do
you know a little stinker no we gotta
introduce Gilbert Adam Gilbert Adam
Gilbert hi on Instagram who is he we
call him little stinker because he has a
bit where he calls himself little
stinker that literally pimp and I
laughed so much at the Montreal Comedy
Festival last year that we broke oh we
actually were on the floor convulsory I
can't wait to see you left it's a little
stinker is great that's what this
episode is sponsored by this show this
episode is sponsored by betterhelp it
has to be it always has always will be
you and I both use it we both talk about
how much it's helped us we both talk
about how much mental health is a big
problem in our country these days and
better help has the qualified
professional licensed therapist to help
you deal with it privacy don't have to
leave your home you don't have to be on
camera it's confidential it's secure
it's Anonymous and basically you're
going to get an online therapist in as
little as what a couple days a couple of
days they'll just come all you do is you
take a quick little survey kind of see
what's going on in your life they match
you up with the person who's best for
you and then boom and then you st and
then you if you don't like them you can
switch up right away they their whole
goal at better help is for you for you
to have the best experience which I
really like uh swear swear swear three
four days ago I turned on a family
member to better help yeah yeah we
talked about they they confided to me
about how they were struggling with
something and which I struggled with and
they never had there before and I
literally was like you should dip a toe
and try better help that's it that's
true betterhelp's awesome and um right
now if you go to betterhelp.com that's
help
betterhelp.com hey babe you're gonna get
10 off your first month that's a huge
discount better help help.com hey babe
10 off your first month go do it dip
your Towing at Sal's family
and I think you've been subscribed a
long long time probably praying fees
you'll never find
uh and I can continue well I don't get
it because it because what rocket money
does is it it's an aggregator it looks
at everything you have a subscription to
and alerts you of it and you could
cancel it right there so you're not
getting hosed by these hoes anymore
listen these hoes ain't loyal see how
they like try it for free for 30 days is
enough time for you to forget about a
subscription and that's what they do all
the time well rocket money comes in and
says okay rocket money says try me and
never join me hold my beer hold me and
then they're gonna make sure if you're
not using it rocket money unsubscribe to
you they make it so easy it was formerly
known as true bill people save average
like 700 bucks a month it's insane a
year sorry yeah yeah it's a personal
finance app that finds and cancels your
unwanted subscriptions monitors your
spending and helps you lower your bills
all in one place this is what I call a
can't lose
there's no reason to not have this
there's absolutely no reason yes this is
there's no downside to it only upside
rocket money and hey babe I want in the
same can't lose can't lose without the
one so right now stop throwing your
money away cancel unwanted subscriptions
and manage your expenses the easy way by
going to rocketmoney.com hey babe that's
rocketmoney.com hey babe rocketmoney.com
hey babe okay question now yeah so you
were there how many nights one night so
you did your show and then after your
show you did mushrooms yeah did you
micro dose mushrooms yes okay so you
didn't do mushrooms no I would I'm gonna
do mushrooms with you yeah because I've
had enough of this you know like you you
go and you come back and not even first
it started with I got drunk and I'm like
wow we don't really get drunk together
yeah and a lot of times you come back
you tell me you get drunk okay then you
say oh the [__] Edibles we don't do
those a lot together yeah and now I'm
doing smelling mushrooms yeah smelling
salt and then mushrooms yeah I mean
you're gonna come back and God forbid
you do like uh
Miley Cyrus what's that called
heroin no country music yeah Molly oh
yeah
oh yeah Molly Cyrus Miley Cyrus
so I mean I sound ancient
I sound ancient but it's just because
I'm at a loss for words lately I I can't
I can't focus lately I started at all
it's not helping but here's the thing
but here's the thing even if you're
sounding ancient you're still like
you're still like the fun older guy
because you're wearing a scissor shirt
that's what it is look at these shoes
look at those shoes no yeah so don't
come back like that I won't do like
cocaine or anything like that no by the
way I heard cocaine bear is excellent I
gotta see it yeah nyp Ray Liotta God
bless him but if you come back the next
level and say you actually dealt the
shrooms or like a Molly I'm gonna be
disappointed and actually don't do Molly
because fentanyl I don't know I don't
want to do it well we could do pure MDMA
though yeah but who are you getting that
from are you getting that from the
government how do you know it's pure we
can get pure MDM everybody everybody
didn't know that it wasn't pure no but
you get the fentanyl strips now that's
all you get you test them but if I'm at
a point right now where I'm testing my
drugs for fentanyl before I do them kick
me in the nuts I don't want to do that I
don't want to be like okay I'm going to
test this to make sure I don't die right
now oh okay the fentanyl by the way who
makes the fentanyl strips how accurate
are they that's true you're gonna base
your life on a fentanyl strip
manufacturer the person making them
fentanyl strips probably knows the
person making the fentanyl it's a good
point I don't know never thought about
it but mushrooms from the Earth
Mushrooms in a pill all right why just
why not test everything you can test
yeah Ayahuasca I think I want to do too
what we're going to do together I told
you I want to do that so we're going to
do it we're going to open up I can't die
from that though right no you cannot
can you change something in your brain
chemistry they give up from all to you
from that they fold because I don't like
that either there's certain cultures in
like Peru that give a shot of Ayahuasca
to their baby moments after they're born
to open up sounds like sound judgment
yep yeah yep that's what they do just
put that baby on a trip before it knows
anything it's already on a trip as soon
as this morning it probably feels like
it's just well there was like an ancient
group of people I think Greek people
that there was they there if there was a
term for them but they were described as
these people who are walking Among Us
died before they died that was the thing
about them that they died before they
died and a lot and there was just like a
thing in history but now the research
that got some of the peoples like they
excavated some of their bones who were
these people to be known to die before
they die in society at that time and
it's they were taking Ayahuasca that's
what they were doing and they were could
see like the afternoon we didn't die
before they died they were just they
would go they would tell people I saw
myself I died I died but I'm alive and
they were like these the ancient healers
and Mystics and all that but they think
they're on Ayahuasca you took
but so that was Wednesday yeah then I
fly from Vancouver will be Thursday
morning 7 A.M flight land in L.A
Thursday flight there's just no options
yeah by the way I was on Air Canada
flight let me tell you something about
Air Canada I was on the Air Canada
flight from New York City to Vancouver
direct flights six and a half hours I
don't know if it's gonna be good or bad
so listen up here Canada if you're
listening and we know that you are
here's the thing Air Canada
the flight okay you had a TV which I
respect I believe I'm not here
talk to Air Canada
hey Air Canada what's up how you doing
I'm I'm Chrissy micro dose now
Air Canada I respect your country I
respect your airline I respect your
foods
when I don't understand is how in 2023
it's Kyle in 2023 bente event how
you have a plane okay that's flying
across North America
that you told me it's getting awkward
within 10 minutes of getting into the
plane when I asked you what the Wi-Fi
was you told me this plane has not been
retrofitted for Wi-Fi there is no Wi-Fi
on this plane it doesn't exist oh blame
Canada and I said what do you mean you
don't have Wi-Fi and she said there's a
select Fleet of planes that don't have
Wi-Fi in the Air Canada Fleet because
they didn't come with Wi-Fi I said when
do you think this plane was built she
told me I know for a fact it was built
in 2021.
I said it doesn't have Wi-Fi
all right it's out there Air Canada we
await your direct response she was like
what are you talking about she was like
you know what take it up with Bloom Cafe
and then I said to her I said and I
actually leaned in the literal the
flight attendant she was like take it up
with blow him down
and then hit me with a with a fist full
of poutine just took him through it
she said to me she goes I swear to
Christ because Canada are nice but
they're passive aggressive she said to
me and I quote she said well now you
won't be distracted by your device you
can enjoy life a little bit
made room right there 45 and she said we
do have to we do have the movies uh that
work and I was like okay and then I
swear to Christ you look like I couldn't
believe it and then multiple people were
asking where's the where's the Wi-Fi and
then she made an announcement to the
first class she made an announcement
maybe about an hour later she said for
everyone who's asking this plane is not
Wi-Fi capable there is no Wi-Fi and I
swear to God she goes there will never
be Wi-Fi on this flight so
she said enjoy your movie yeah read a
book or look out the window I swear to
Christ who team sounds like slang for
vagina doesn't us yeah yeah she did
begin towards the end of the flight by
the way she did begin to flirt with me
by the end of flight she's a 55 year old
middle-aged Canadian woman from Edmonton
I knew everything yeah if she doesn't
want to give up poutine you want the
best poutine you ever had
what what is where did poonani come from
as slang for vagina what's poonanny poon
pooncho for punani but which punani mean
by the I don't know uh I need you to
answer me now I need you no matter what
even if you don't know it give me an
answer poonani punani was um I'm gonna
say uh invented by young gravy uh I mean
that's a very good guess he's being
super recessively by the way is he yeah
oh my God
yeah we got to get him on the Pod I know
please come on young gravy with
will be gone and then have Rick Astley
walk through the door oh
[Applause]
wow so what is beautiful flower but it's
oh but that's the origin from a German
that's nice I'm a Jamaican Creole word
well that at least has a good etymology
do you know when people you ever look up
what why people is called women broads I
think it's actually like a slab of beef
I think I read this really abroad is
like it was an old term for like a slab
of like beef or something like that look
that up
yeah but why
maybe I thought it was like I had to do
something with meat meal ticket
calling a girl a meal ticket's funny
[Laughter]
what's offensive I mean I wouldn't say
if you say broad but like people
what's more call somebody hey this is a
broad this is my chick broad I like to
say my old lady but that's just because
I like old-fashioned things I don't know
if that's insulting but how is that but
because what to call somebody my old
lady when they're you know 27 years old
but I don't understand that I don't it's
just a turn meaning you're you know ball
and chain my my little old lady
it might be all like oh it's like uh
yeah I think it was like that's what
they I don't know I don't know but I
like it I find it endearing but you
don't hear my old guy
because what do you call your husband
you know I wouldn't say my all yeah my
old husband uh yeah ball and chain yeah
I don't know I don't know I had a
passive aggressive uh where was I coming
out of
just this week uh I was coming out of DC
I think passive aggressive waitress at
the server at the airport restaurant
butcher box if you love meat in your
mouth which why else would you listen to
Hey babe yeah butcher box is for you
literally butcher box we've we both uh
subscribe
they started sending it to us because
they started sponsoring the show but
then we actively bought because it
literally you can never have too much of
their stuff it's unbelievable no joke
two two pork chops we cooked like three
nights ago it takes the guesswork with
Dave Williamson's dry rub shout out
shout out table instrument it takes the
guesswork out of finding high quality
Meat and seafood you can trust because a
lot of times your Quality Meat and
seafood is just outright lying to you
that's right by the way I don't know how
to choose I'm not contrary to popular
belief uh 100 grass-fed beef organic
chicken pork raised crate free and wild
caught seafood and that's the other
thing that's really good right you don't
want stuff that's shut up with all the
antibiotics you don't want any of that
and right now that's why we got the deal
for you all you got to do is go to
butcherbox.com hey babe and use the code
hey babe you're gonna get a 100
grass-fed chunk roast and a whole
chicken free in your birthday lost
twenty dollars off okay all you gotta do
grass-fed chuck roast then they handed a
whole chicken they give you a whole
chicken at butcherbox.com hey babe 100
grass-fed chocolate and a whole organic
chicken free when you join plus an
additional 20 off your first box sign up
today at butcherbox.com hey babe use
code hey babe that deal is amazing and
send us pictures of that whole chicken
yes
we were we had a flight 22 minutes we
were boarding place was empty we walk in
we sit down she comes over she goes she
takes a while to come over then she
comes over I said hey I said we want to
order breakfast I said but we're
boarding in 22 minutes in your honest
opinion do you think that we can get the
breakfast paid for and be done in 22
minutes she goes well if you stop
talking to me and asking me questions in
order you might
she said it just like that and I was
like and then she walked away she came
back she dropped menus and she's like so
and then she walked back and I said to I
was with two guys to my friends and I
was like I almost want to get up and
leave yeah that was something else so
then I was like then I appreciate it a
little bit I don't know I don't know how
to feel about it did you get the
breakfast in 22 minutes we I I literally
brought half I brought it onto the plane
it was and it was an avocado toast and
she gave it to me at the 20 minute mark
but she said that and she walked away
and I was like I was almost like in
shock right I was like damn yeah like
that was not really passive aggressive
it was kind of a kind of aggressive
aggressive I was like what's
[__] huh a few tough terms for
men would be Geezer yeah fuddy duddy
okay I think would be the modern
of a lot but that's not similar to old
lady like your old lady wouldn't say
this is my [__] yeah no fuddy duddy
that's what that means a guy I just
thought a funny duddy meant like a like
a like a you know like a like a I
thought a funny daddy was a candy bar
it's a good name for one funny daddy
he's real funny daddy like like a wet
blanket you know yeah you know what I
mean yeah like a wet blanket is I don't
even know what that means it's a wet
blanket I know what it means what does
it come from like a real pill no I don't
know I don't really don't know yeah it's
just I guess a soppy dull it says
old-fashioned or fussy is it funny okay
so why would you call your guy that
yeah it doesn't make sense to me I think
chick it's like derogatory and also coot
c-o-o-t good where's chick come from
I guess my chick a little baby chick
they're cute you want to have sex with
it
um so Wednesday I got Thursday I landed
in LA from Vancouver
that's why I did have Wi-Fi i i i i that
Air Canada that was West yet WestJet
which is I think like the Jet Blue it's
a Canadian Airline it's not bad so I
land Thursday get to the hotel the
addition bank or LAX LAX Edition hotels
did I tell you about that one tell me
about the one great hotel and I love the
smell in there that I am I asked the
person I said even if it costs great
Lobby whatever it costs me to to give me
that information give me that
information right now right on a piece
of paper I want you to get in trouble
tell me what the scent is I needed in my
house I needed my life and they just
told me out loud for everyone to hear
what it was okay La Bamba something like
that I have it written down La Bamba La
Bamba Richie Valens yes no was it La was
it um
it was probably black and white okay
yeah they got some brick and mortars
yeah yeah in New York pricing yeah yeah
so I put it on the company or hey babe
card yeah so I I lay labo
um I'm surprised you don't know about
them because they're santal 33 is
sweeping the nation really I have it in
the house I first found about laylabo
santile 33 when I stayed at a hotel in
Amsterdam wow and I was like this stuff
is smells so good and I associate it
with that trip but then I smelled it on
people and I was like okay I don't love
it as much on people but it is a really
good smell yo I think you'll love it do
you have the lava when you walk into
your house you have the labo that greets
me I have products laylabo products okay
like like lotion and things like that
because honestly I'll take but we bought
some but we take it if it's in the hotel
because it's it's like dude I'm not
kidding you like a thing this big is
like 100 bucks it's like no I know what
that I tried to take it from the
additional hotel but it's locked on the
wall because so many people were
stealing me oh it's a push yeah but you
know what you do that you go to CVS you
get yourself a travel container you pump
that right it's still a lava yeah I'll
still steal it a little so a lot so I do
that land at one I have to be at the
Jimmy Kimmel show at four so it's tiring
you know I microwave right there though
what I did is I did my 100 push-ups 100
sit-ups I had to do that shout out
athlean X on YouTube that's a great
Fitness follow athlean X the guy who
runs athlean X his name is Jeff cesari
or Jeff something is the most ripped
individual you've ever seen in life
almost to the point where it's almost
like I'm almost like you have too many
muscles like it's because he's not like
like you could tell this guy everything
he fine-tunes his body to the point
where I'm like does he even have skin or
is he just all muscle he looks like he's
in the body's exhibit is that good
though no yes dude he's in phenomenal
he's like P1 million x yeah he's
phenomenal shape and knows the science
of exercise he's so uh he's gonna live
to like a hundred and he's gonna he's
got to knock up blood he died yesterday
wow believe it or not drop down yeah and
take it up what can you do he but he he
um he's so ripped and so intelligent uh
with uh he's a physical therapist and
anyway so you know I follow what he do
so I just pushed myself a little bit
that's at 4 30.
they've come to pick us up get to the
Jimmy Kimmel show put on my suit sleeves
too high put it on there I put it on
there I walked in it
worked a purple sweater and and and
jeans that vanity leave with an honor to
change back I I I kept it on vanitya did
I is she said it's good the sweater's
Too Short okay so so
um I uh not everyone has money to dry
clean every time all the time but
so but Venetia does it and she uses the
no press card right so so so
I so I go to Jimmy Kimmel yeah do Jimmy
Kimmel think that's it gonna go rest
Jimmy says come to my groom and says I
want to take you to dinner I said now I
have to go to that who are you with uh I
was with the Italian woman my manager
Emilio and then Jimmy's uh head of his
production company he's not only with
one person she did a four-person dinner
that's good it's better than one-on-one
went out to uh uh uh something great
in L.A where'd you go uh uh it's like an
Italian Steakhouse it was excellent okay
yes that's where he was oh there's one
in L.A there's a famous One in New York
you mean what does Joe and that woman's
Nancy Richardson I don't know I don't
know restaurants
I was out of Syria that's one of the
best restaurants there is in L.A it was
fantastic Italian Italian now it wasn't
my day to eat sweets but compliments to
the chef because when you were Jimmy
Kimmel you're always going to get
complicated say the chef brought out a
dessert that I've never it was on it was
like a pudding with a wafer you like
your balls there I left my balls there I
did not eat those [__] sweets because
I will not lie to my daughter oh so you
didn't leave your balls there I know I
won't I won't cheat I won't cheat on I'm
never gonna lie to my daughter now I did
technically eat sweets did you talk
about the mushrooms I didn't tell them
about the mushrooms because they're not
sweets continue I I technically here's
the thing because I think Delilah my
daughter she says you can't eat sweets
you could only eat sweet Saturday but I
think when we made that bet she was she
was talking about New York time she was
not factoring in time zone I could see
that so I ate my sweets a little early
but it was different times okay so I
would love to know about this you're not
gonna believe this well you will because
it's not that different but I talked
about that restaurant twice in the last
three days and said literally the next
time I go to eat I'm making a
reservation there here in New York
let me call Jimmy Kimmel I did a little
I did a little overnight staycation I
had to do serious and so I gotta booked
a hotel and I went to lunch at Maria
have you been to Maria no very expensive
but it was good uh and then I went to uh
uh uh where the [__] did I go to at
night oh uh Quality Meats love quality
good meal it was a good meal what hotel
did you selling I stayed at the Conrad
hotel I like the Conrad hotel in the
Lower East Side I mean in the best park
there's two okay there's one in Midtown
54th Street because I had to go to
sirius I went for a walk in the park the
next morning it was snowing real New
York moment Central Park yep you know
what you got to eat I'm gonna give you a
place Blue Hill I'm about to go to no
tomorrow where the hell is that it's uh
West Village amazing it's great man it's
it's awesome yeah they just bring stuff
out no no menu and they just ask you if
you're allergic to any but they bring
out their parts like eight eight or nine
courses what did they bring out well
then you could tell them that okay yeah
they're not they're not dictators yeah I
um so so that was Thursday Kimmel then
we do dinner at Jimmy Kimmel uh you know
chemicals did you offer did you reach of
course you reached I reached you if you
reach your Amelia reach no I reached you
reached and he was like don't buy
everything he was like he said did you
insist he said literally he said Chris
if you if you reach any further into
your pocket I'm gonna [__] kill you
he said that exact quote so so I said
okay he's a violent guy yeah he's known
for that it's not right yeah threatening
you you just started the relationship
yeah so he said I'll [__] kill you
and I think he said he killed my family
as well so I just I I said something a
little far yeah but you know and so so
then that's I don't like the guy now be
honest
well he loves you and so and so Thursday
night that we get we get done about I
don't know 11 right Friday morning
let me tell you that's when I kicked off
the Austin kicked off let me tell you
stay at the Austin Soho so he said
no no no no no Friday night no Friday
even better than the Austin Soho I
stayed at the Holiday Inn Express in
Fresno no no because you had a flight no
I I no here's here's the thing here
because you're I had a show in Fresno I
had a show Friday night in Fresno then I
had Saturday night in San Jose Sunday
night in Sacramento I just did it I just
did this exact leg Fresno San Jose
you know we should go next time when you
do San Jose in Sacramento Santa Rosa
dude gangbusters beautiful shout out to
Santa Rosa shout it out that was that oh
no that was the last one it was one of
my favorite shows if not my favorite of
the entire tour Santa Rosa Santa Rosa
exact opposite of Vancouver exact
opposite I was like I wish I I wished I
was taped that would have been my
special that's how good it was so so so
the weather in California you've heard
about on the news I've never in my life
seen snowing raining I will show you
videos of 30 minute difference I've also
never seen this in my life this was sad
the rain was so bad bad like so insanely
bad where like my guy was driving Tommy
tours Tommy Russo Tommy TT Jerry here he
is a great driver but I had to say I was
like dude if you don't feel comfortable
doing this like let me know like we
don't have to oh
it's raining when we drove Boston yeah
and you fell asleep for five hours dude
my call was hydroplating
but we saw we you know we hit some
traffic around like a road we saw a car
I've never seen a car two cars flipped
over all the contents of the car like
the the all of it all you saw a post
happening no but we were there we saw
the ambulances the we saw the police
were there but the ambassy driving
[__] sheet over bodies but like
literally like where we were like
driving past that we're like I don't
know if you well you said you've
experienced that if you haven't it is a
feeling where you're like so then have
to try to do comedy in a few hours I was
like it was like even Tommy who's like
you know seen some stuff like that
before he's from upstate he's like this
is like because you just see that [__]
in Albany he was like he was like this
is like crazy like I was like dude
terrible it was horrifying to see
um and so the weather was so [__] bad
a three-hour drive from LA to Fresno
took us eight hours we get to Fresno
moments before the show
come out do the show in Fresno shout out
to Tower Theater fun time
next morning we have to drive from
Fresno to San Jose it's a actual snow
blizzard which the first time in 60
years has ever snowed in that part of
California we're driving through that
get to see any part of that fun
um it was fun because Tommy is such like
a young innocent good kid he was excited
to be seeing California never been
California he was excited to be seeing
California in this way that so many
people have never seen him before so he
was making it fun his energy was making
it fun he's like this is awesome yeah so
I was like okay but literally Fresno
shout out Fresno um but Fresno is one of
those places you get in you get out yeah
I thought that we were driving through
we were driving through then a part of
California called Stockton California
[__] the Stockton slap baby Stockton
slap I know what that is it literally
looked like switzerlands
brother yeah
they're famously from Stockton they slap
people in MMA fights and they called the
stock to slap Yeah well yeah I that I I
it was one of those things where
Stockton look like Switzerland to me
because of how that noise yeah and then
the show in San Jose great
um then the show and then we had to then
we drive from San Jose and San Jose the
California theater Civic Auditorium no
California theater okay how did you like
that crowd great crowd by the way all
the crowds were great everything also
sack always blows my sack off sack I
went to the Crest theater yeah so
Sacrament but here's the thing drove
from San Jose to Sacramento okay then
the only red eye the only red I I could
get on was back out of San Francisco to
get to Austin so I had to drive two
hours back go get on the overnight
flight to Austin landed at 5 a.m I did
it slept for two hours and then went to
Segura Rogan kill Tony and I'm Jack
Point you're on fumes man I was
literally on fumes got [__] I by the
the last 20 minutes of Joe Rogan I do
not remember I blackout drunk I don't
know what I said oh yo you drank drank
an entire bottle of tequila and smoke
weed I did smelling salts you smoked
weed on it yeah see I would be hesitant
to do that out of the gate because
sometimes when I smoke weed I'm not
either I'm too high and I'm not I'm not
a great conversationalist because I'm
just like my thoughts are all over or I
get in my own head and I actually am
less so like you need to take maybe a
puff to loosen you up but if I smoke too
much I'm not going to be good I'm
surprised you weren't nervous about that
what do you offering you didn't want to
say no I can't you can't say no and I
just come from Tom Segura show and I
felt like on top of the Moon because Tom
is so awesome I just felt good I felt
like I could do anything with his wife
with Christina you know it's just I
actually filled it on two bears one cave
that comes out on March 27th so so um
but literally and then I get you know
and then you know I got home last night
drinking and he's smoking weed yeah on
the three hours on the three hours and I
blacked out the last 10 minutes I don't
know what I said I have no idea what I
said at some point I started defending
Stomp and frisk I know that
so and that got all that's got some
interesting comments but I was blackout
and um and so and so did you do that
with Jimmy Kimmel yeah yeah yeah did
that come out over the Osteria Mozart
dinner and uh and then and then I get
home I got home uh yesterday and I and I
you know so Tony they're smoking and
drinking on that too Tony smoking
drinking we had you drank on that
sodas probably yeah no I couldn't I
couldn't because I drank the whole
bottle of tequila with Rogan fell asleep
for 30 minutes I feel like your mother
did you eat anything no I checked my
zero fasting app my time was up so I had
to just suck it up and I didn't eat
again till I got I I had to I had to I
had to because my sweaters are going to
keep getting shorter so I had to I can't
gain a pound did you get sick I would
have started feeling like Hydra did you
say hydrated I stayed hydrated stay
tuned folks I'm gonna ask him all the
questions I stayed hydrated I got a
vitamin C uh drip thing to get hydration
you have to [__] did you get that you
have to they come to the house
I only got home yeah a c or a B see oh
I've never done a c I did a B12 no I did
a c they came they came to the house
sick in Atlanta two shows to the hotel I
heard that it's supposed to be good I
did it it [__] works really I was
laid out like almost like a flu in the
day I went and I did two shows I I I I
if I didn't do that I would not have
been able to do it yeah yeah so did it
work for you
um it worked for well I wasn't sick like
that but I I was feeling like really run
down yesterday but I want to you know
see my kids and whatever a rock dock is
that what they called it uh they call it
a rock dock this was the IV IV person
Island yeah they just came came to the
house and then did they know you no no
no good and then I said I said well at
least I have I said at least I have the
entire week now to rest and then pimp
text what time are we doing hey babe
tomorrow and then what time are we doing
Chrissy Chaos on Thursday and then I
also have committed to five shows
through the weekend at The Comedy Cellar
so it's one of those things you didn't
need to do those seller shows no you
didn't need to do those I should not
have done them well here's the thing
folks now you know if you see me if uh
well that Mike Lavin will be at the at
the car that's my fake name is Mike
Lavin right um at the comedy Center so
maybe the people you know oh do you fake
name it now I have to because Radio City
okay September 22nd Rainbow City might
be adding a show in the New York area
um so so yeah so so I am I will tell you
what I'm starting to and that's why I'm
saying all that to say that's why I was
given the smelling salts by Rogan
because he knew how tired I was because
he was like you're doing so much he he
told me he was like nobody does sugura
on my show and kill Tony in the same day
nope nobody does that I said well what
do you have he said I'm gonna bring
something out for you that's going to
wake you the [__] up okay and he brought
out the salts which sugar Sean the MMA
fighter sure reached out to me about uh
the salts uh reached out to you about
the salts reached out to me about the
episode the salt uh my watch and just
talking to me about Rogan do you know
him no no I know of him but he's going
to come here is he fun guys
exciting to watch really cool yeah yeah
he should kick us both in the face knock
us unconscious and then get the salts
out yeah we'll try that this has been
hey babe
uh
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away from your feelings babe don't
be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate to say hey babe hey babe hey
babe hey babe